bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'aktu
dans quelques instants on va parler de
cinéma du festival des cultures urbaines
à plaisir mais d'abord ces deux images
la première c'était hier soir lors du
trophée culture et diversité organisé
par déclic théâtre la troupe
d'improvisation de trappe alors comme
lors des phases finales le président de
la république françois hollande voilà
vous le découvrez visiblement séduit par
l'exercice est revenu saluer les
collégiens pour cette phase finale cinq
villes de france ont participé à
travailler une année qui a rassemblé
quelques 360 élèves le théâtre
d'improvisation comme art à part entière
c'est le message du président de la
république message d'ailleurs relais
relayé par benoît hamon le ministre de
l'éducation nationale on les écoute je
suis là par intérêt pour vous parce que
vous faites
parce que vous réalisez et digne
effectivement de respect ce que vous
faites à travers l'improvisation
théâtrale devra être progressivement
stimuler généralisée parce que nous
avons besoin que vous trouviez dans le
thé à une forme de confiance de
réalisation d'intérêt pour l'éducation
pour le savoir pour la connaissance pour
la culture est également 2
l'option terrain existe déjà au niveau
du baccalauréat liste est encouragée dès
le collège pour que vous puissiez aller
dans cette direction
rock surtout à chacun de ces jeunes
sanaa une grande confiance en soi et
aix est absolument clé sur toi un match
comme celui là qu'un âge parfois un peu
compliqué on cherche et ça apprend
notamment
on regarde ces matchs d'improvisation à
se glisser dans les pas de l'autre dans
les initiatives de l'équipe d'en face
c'est souvent comme ça d'ailleurs pro
fini par gagner les matchs d'impro on
improvise mais il ya des règles et ça
prend tout ça à la fois
ce qui m'amène à penser que dans le
cadre de la fameuse réforme des rythmes
scolaires qui permet
ok on encourage les devil a proposé des
activités au delà du temps d'école voilà
une chose qui va peut-être falloir qu'on
développe et comptera véridique de
bordeaux
il le trophée culture et diversité un
sujet complet retrouver demain dans
l'émission culturelle cas les autres
images cette fois ci c'était ce mardi en
fin d'après midi la visite d'olivier
besancenot tête de liste npa nouveau
parti anticapitaliste la tête de liste
donc de la région ile-de-france pour les
élections européennes
il est à quelques instants il était au
technocentre renault de guyancourt il a
aussi rencontré là les salariés de psa à
poissy à 40 ans olivier besancenot fait
donc son come back sur la scène de
politique elle son idée phare pour les
élections ne plus autoriser les partis
institutionnels à parler au nom des
français
il conduit donc dit il une liste de
militants de salariés de chômeurs il
veut une europe des travailleurs et des
peuples
en juin 2004 lors des européennes
olivier besancenot tête de liste elle au
lcr en ile-de-france avait rassemblé
2,78 % des suffrages et n'avait pas
obtenu de siège
il veut faire une démonstration
militante et donc donner la parole à des
personnes qui ne l'ont pas
habituellement on les couteaux micro
d'anthony rech
nous on serait pour une autre europe ce
qu'on appelle une robe des travailleurs
et des peuples c'est à dire on prendre
le meilleur de du droit social ou du
droit démocratique qui peut exister dans
un pays ce que veut faire partager entre
tous et puis envoyé dans une assemblée
qui constitueraient des règles
démocratiques des gens et des élus qu
aurait comme seul motif justement de
construire une europe qui fonctionne à
l'invers à l'envers de celle qu'on
connaît actuellement c'est à dire du bas
vers le haut plutôt du haut vers le bas
je crois qu'il ya vraiment il ya une
coupure est ce que les gens ont leur dis
à chaque fois qu'il ya des il ya des
mauvais coups qui nous tombe dessus
c'est la faute de l'europe c'est la
faute de l'europe alors qu'on sait bien
qu effectivement c'est pas les députés
européens qui décide de tout mais bien
les chefs d'état et donc à un jeu comme
ça où les députés disent nous on n'a pas
les pouvoirs on peut rien faire et puis
les chefs d'état dit c'est la faute de
la robe c'est pas nous à un moment donné
je crois qu'il faut arrêter ça c'est
cinéma
allez on change tout à fait de
thématiques on va partir du côté de
cannes avec vous savez le partenariat
avec radio sensations alors à cannes
pendant le festival il n'y a pas que les
films en compétition la croisette est
aussi célèbre pour ses soirées et ce
lundi soir le groupe gauche originaire
de versailles a donné un concert privé
devant des producteurs américains
l'occasion pour les festivaliers
présents de découvrir les titres de leur
deuxième album
mira sorti il ya quelques semaines
seulement on trouve que ce festival
génère un esprit de fête et nous on aime
bien l'esprit de fête faire des parties
s'amuser faire danser les gens c'est là
les gens viennent pour se détendre donc
celle à qui les gens sont sur le plus
réceptif et envie de s'éclater
c'est un public différent du public de
la capitale par exemple qui vient
vraiment c'est la capitale qui descend
dans le sud pour se divertir et nous on
tombe à pic pour ça ça nous permet de
montrer notre musique à un autre public
de professionnels à ça quand on joue
dans des salles c'est plutôt des
professions de la musique qui peuvent
venir
et là c'est des professionnels du cinéma
et c'est un secteur aussi qui nous
intéresse beaucoup
dans le but de faire des musiques de
films
même même pourquoi pas la publicité ou
des choses comme ça des documentaires
voilà et pour info le groupe muse sera
en concert demain au trianon à paris
alors on va maintenant parler du premier
festival des cultures urbaines cela se
passe du côté de plaisir qu'il korda
bonsoir vous êtes battus au maire chargé
de la culture
la ville de plaisir organismes donc son
premier festival il a démarré le 16 mai
il se termine le 25 mai et des
expositions il ya les ateliers de la
danse du graffiti vu un bateau les mêmes
du spectacle pour enfants de maya
notamment un conte musical pour les plus
petits alors pourquoi un festival des
cultures urbaines c'était une demande
d'habitants d'associations mais bien
effectivement avec notre mère mme
joséphine comme max bergé nous étions
arrivés au constat qu'après quelques
activités ponctuelles les années
précédentes
il était venu d'offrir finalement une
activité un peu plus structuré sous
forme d'un festival un petit peu plus
complet mettant en évidence
finalement cet aspect créatif née de la
ville sur un plateau un petit peu plus
complet avec l'ensemble des disciplines
comme vous venez de le rappeler car
beaucoup de discipline et aussi cinq
lieux qui sont investis pour ce festival
des cultures urbaines et des lieux assez
assez étonnant pour lie à la clé des
champs sans à dire c'est plutôt
classique poitras et adapté théâtre
robert manuel donc c'est un peu plus
grands à la salle déjà dans la cour des
copains qui est plutôt connu pour ses
expositions vers un peu plus classique
il ya aussi la mosaïque et le parc du
château
c'était important comme ça va investir
des lieux très différents dans la vie
mais alors c'est quelque chose qu'on
prône régulièrement sur la ville
puisqu'on a déjà plusieurs
manifestations comme ce qu'on fait en
cette période les beaux jours culturel
où on fait sortir les plaisirs on a un
petit peu à l'extérieur mais par
principe les lieux culturels ne doivent
pas être exclusif et donc l'idée c'est
de faire découvrir cette culture urbaine
à des gens qu'on avait peut-être pas
ou envies ou l'idée de les voir et donc
on se promenant dans le parc du château
tout simplement d'être sollicité par la
curiosité et d'aller voir découvrir cela
évidemment après on a les valeurs sûres
plus classiques comme la clé des champs
où l'idée est de ne pas permettre aux
jeunes de continuer à investir ce lieu
qui leur est complètement destinée on va
pas complètement détaillé le programme
parce qu'il ya un brando qui plus est
d'afficher donc on peut se renseigner
mais quand même demain il ya un conte
musical pour les petits de ma pré midi
mercredi suite au non les petits vont
slam et d'écouté traditionnellement les
comptes ou les balades contées sont un
peu plus aussi sur des thèmes assez
classique et on se rend compte que il ya
des comptes un petit peu plus modernes
issus de la ville qui sont intéressants
d'aider ces âges là et puis les
solliciter un petit peu le challenge est
sûre justement quelques l'interaction
visuelle et sonore pour leur montrer un
petit peu l'intérêt en tout cas à leur
faire découvrir quelque chose qu'ils ne
connaissent pas forcément
alors ça c'est le conte musical c'est
pour demain et demain aussi tout
l'après-midi aussi des ateliers de
graffitis qu'on retrouvera peut-être
aussi d'immenses parce qu'il ya un mur
d'expression libre graffitis mais l'idée
c'est que j'ai pas blanc que saddam
n'est cité que jeune plaisir voilà les
graphes
non non parce que justement l'idée c'est
de montrer que c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on fait n'importe comment on aura des
professionnels qui vont venir faire une
démonstration
non seulement il ya une exposition
permanente tout au long de la semaine
mais on aura une démonstration en temps
réel on aura des échanges de discussions
avec ces artistes qui permettront de
comprendre que c'est pas faire ça
n'importe où n'importe comment c'est
passé un message artistique structuré et
donc offrir effectivement un mur
d'expression libre qui sera peut-être
devrait exposer après ailleurs ou
réutilisés voilà
nous paraissait intéressant aux
graffitis je les dis danse hip hop
aussi ces ateliers sont gratuits oui
alors c'est une démarche qu'on a
régulièrement les concerts à la clé des
chansons sont quand même payant en règle
générale à des tarifs intéressants
surtout pour les étudiants
mais c'est vrai que la plupart des
activités proposées sur le plan culturel
sur la ville sont gratuites
est-ce qu'on peut dresser un premier
bilan alors il ya eu samedi dimanche un
concert de reggae spectacle aussi pour
les enfants ce week-end est ce que ça a
pris ça a bien pris on est content de
l'audience et puis l'a déjà ce soir on
fait le bilan que beaucoup d'inscrits
pour les prochaines activités et donc
dépêchez vous de vous inscrire si vous
souhaitez participer parce qu'il n'y
aura pas la place pour tout le monde
mais ça fait rien à l'essentiel c'est de
venir voir même si on n'est pas
forcément directement dans la
participation le fait de discuter de
voir des d'échangés le but c'est
vraiment de se rencontrer entre
associations professionnelles et puis
c'est un plaisir wadan dans la promenade
parce que c'est important d'expliquer
aussi que ce festival il ya des troupes
professionnelles il a évité le sujet
pour initier à l'art du graffiti
il ya aussi les associations locales qui
ont été sollicités pour les parties
voilà qui sont déjà très active qui nous
propose beaucoup de choses tout au long
de l'année qui sont contentes de
s'inclure dans ce festival
donc merci qui travaillent ne sont pas
tous et merci à l'ami tu donc fi
festival pardon des cultures urbaines à
plaisir c'est jusqu'au 25 mai il ya
plein d'activités notamment mercredi et
surtout le week-end prochain donc à ne
pas manquer merci à vous merci
ce journal est maintenant terminé merci
de l'avoir suivi dans quelques instants
le débat europe avec à wilfrid de réchy
un débat entre eux des représentants ump
ps fn et europe ecologie les verts bonne
soirée à vous